oh my god y'all would not believe this  why why what the Beyonce song that came  out my phone and blew up this [ __ ] is  crazy I knew it was coming but I didn't  know it was coming today I was not  expecting this to drop so fast and god  oh my like this is something that you  wish for your whole life but you never  prepare for it  it is excited no this is me I'm so  excite here your mama would be proud I  don't know what to do I gotta go treat  myself I'm gonna realize to be thank you  what is it like a cause um no I'm like  to Red Lobster and get myself a lobster  you got me we'll come on but you gotta  earn it first we can't really go to  realize the first boy come on here